all right minister seymour yes sir mr
seymour good to see you again god bless
you good to see you too man
how are things in chicago
beautiful there's just so much killing
in chicago right now is there
it's it's it's
it's bad right now man
you're on the west side right i'm all
over really
i'm working with the
the young gang bangers and the dope
dealers talking to them to put the guns
down right now
and uh which they don't want to you know
what do you think the problem is in
chicago
well number one we got dirty cops in
chicago number one
and young brothers they asking for help
and they can't get help they're looking
for jobs
they won't give them jobs you know they
got to eat man you know so
they fighting against one another's and
it's a war
and i talked to them all the time i said
man if i can
keep one foot out the penitentiary
and one out the graveyard i'll continue
can help you guys
you know it's it's hard man you know
they fighting for their life and they
fighting to eat man and
and nothing's gonna be did about it man
until
we come together we can come together
it's still
it's bad man yeah they don't have role
models they kind of show them the way
well the role models is all them guys
strung out man you know it's bad man
a lot of them don't have mothers and
fathers they're grandmothers you know
it's
passing on and
they really raise their self the young
boys really raising themselves you know
they're in the street all all day all
night
they don't have no guidance no love
but once i see them a lot of time i talk
to them and i let them shoot videos with
some of my cars you know i got some of
the elegant cars luxury cars you know
rolls royce and lamborghini's
majorities and uh bentley's you know and
uh
i put my cars out there and let them
shoot videos free don't charge them you
know so i do got some power over them
right now
but you're trying to
just help them with a little bit of your
knowledge and wisdom yeah i'm trying to
help them you know but some guidance
a lot of them uh them cocaine babies
eight
lot of them uh was born in 85 to crack
cocaine back then
and uh them crack cocaine babies was
messed up man so a lot of them if you
tell them no they still gonna do it you
know so
you really gotta sit down and listen to
these cats and see where they're coming
from because they don't have no guidance
man
you know but i'm gonna keep talking to
him and i'm gonna keep helping because
someone had to help me man you know i
came from
a christian family my mother and father
was a preacher ministers okay i was a
preacher kid and the preacher kids was
in trouble all the time and i was in
trouble all the time
the preacher kids kept up a lot of mess
so i thank god to look at me now man i'm
i'm uh i got
you know i got 20 something
grandchildren i'm a great grandfather
you know
so and i love the uh to be around my
grandbabies that's what really took me
out the streets i had to raise my sons
some daughters and put them in private
schools you know live the life that i
live i live the fast life but i want no
angel i've done everything but that and
i thank god i'm still standing i want to
say out there today to mothers and
fathers
try to sit around and talk to your your
your grandchildrens your children's and
let them know that you love them
and that's all they're looking for right
now is love
if we can take time out there
to show them some love that's what
they're looking for love and a job a lot
of them want to work man
and a lot of them are not going to work
they run they carry big old pistols big
old guns and what i say about the police
is they so bad they so dirty they don't
know how to talk to you
mothers and fathers
try to talk to the police sir man i talk
to you they don't know how to say yes
how you doing they really disrespectful
and you know that's what really make the
young brothers
the young boys and girls
not listen to the police also because
the police
don't play fair they don't play fair in
chicago majority
6 65 75 percent of them is dirty okay
you got some good cops out there
but the young boys be trying to talk to
them they put guns and drugs on them
they bring in they bring in a lot of
young boys and girls back to court on a
lot of police officers have been putting
drugs on them now they standing up to
talk
for their self
but if the police would be 50
right i think we have a better chance
the young boys don't want to hear they
don't want to hit nothing they want a
high court in the middle of the street
they want to shoot
they don't respect the law no more
because the law don't respect them if
the law gets them respect
we have a chance
we have a chance it's worse on the south
side of chicago than the west side right
man
it's worse everywhere
a lot of stuff don't make the news
so much killing man young girls out
there gang banging now they're rough
they rougher than the boys they can
pistols now man
so you all you got to do not today just
shut up and be quiet mind your business
just mind your business hello and bye
keep walking down the street wherever
you go is a war
now you're one of the more successful
gentleman in the game
well and and i think you probably had
some side
businesses that were helpful
well i always
fed the black community
i gave 500 turkeys away this year
i gave uh uh
uh
about 400 hams
i gave a half a semi
or toys away
this year
i gave a lot of clothes away to the kids
uh the funeral homes i've been getting
soups
to bury the young brothers
you know and i i have been uh supporting
the west side community dressing the
young kids for the
the proms and going
going for graduation i just been
supporting my brothers and sisters
i just job i have to do i have to give
back
you know so when you learn to give back
you be blessed
and the neighbors see what you're doing
and they with you and they will listen
i'm feeding a lot of people man i'm
feeding a lot of people help a lot of
people in my community and this help
that you you're providing is something
you've done
later in life or you did throughout your
life i've been doing it i just been
doing it for the last uh
25 years
giving giving away giving away to the
community
closing a lot of people a lot of young
boys gym shoes
clothes you know them young kids want to
go to school but you you came from a
similar background to these kids that
you're helping
i think which is right now you came from
a similar background to these kids that
you're helping well
not that i came from a lot of them i've
seen a lot of them grow up their mother
and father we went to school together
with sonoma
and i seen some of them in the community
i worked on a lot of them
cars you know and they support my place
of business so i try to give back
because
me and my sons we you know we got a
beauty shop a barber shop and
construction company
we have a credit repair uh first
impression credit repair chade's barber
shop on 56
61 west chicago avenue flipside auto
body shop 4519 was lake street i own a
fur company downtown on oak street
and so i do a lot of
a lot
for the community because i make a
little money and i try to help him give
back
what do you think the younger generation
among uh
it's i know it's not a simple problem
but i mean
there's a lack of education
a lot of them don't get a chance to go
to school and a lot of them aren't going
to go to school all they know is about
guns and drugs that's all there's lack
of opportunity
i don't even think they've taken
opportunity if they had it well if they
had an opportunity
i believe
let's say 50 50.
and see if when you grew up
in the black community
no money
no food on the table no mother and
father the mothers and fathers in jail
mothers and fathers is passed on so the
grandmothers and the grandfathers try to
do the best they can if they have a
grandmother
and a grandfather then you got young
kids
if you have children at home try to keep
them and take care
because they go to foster
homes
they're going to get abused
the babysitters abused me when i was
coming up so it was rough on me my mom
and dad when i was a little boy
so my grandmama raised me and my daddy
did the best he could for me but i seen
a lot in my days
it come from home the girls getting
raped the boys getting raped
man
i i had a heart coming up so
if we
can show love to our loved ones
i believe we have a better chance today
we got to show love it's no love
and they took the whooping out the house
you can't whoop your children if you're
whooping you're going to jail
so
they got us trapped
we
trapped until we come
and go back to the old landmark the old
school whoop your children when they're
doing wrong
they ain't gonna let us do that
[Music]
what was the most difficult period of
your life
my daddy didn't play
you know my mama died when i was like uh
seven eight years old i remember my mama
she didn't play she was a saved woman my
father was a saved man he went to church
he was a preacher how'd you lose your
mom
huh how did your mom pass away well she
she was in the state institution she
lost her mind
some kind of way
she got burned up in the state
institutional hospital she got into it
with some nurses
and some nurses
she jumped three nurses next next
day
they put a room on fire
so i lost my mama when i was a little
kid you know
yeah so that's sad but
what can i do
it made me strong today just
trying to do the right thing you know
work i ca i work all the time my sons
they work on cars
working on buildings building motels
building houses
and uh
i'm glad that i put a lot of time in
with mine i put a lot of time in my i
would mine
i don't care what they said i wouldn't
mind cause i know
when none not there
my sons had never got no weapons
i can look at them
they gotta whoop them but i can look at
them a certain way they get somewhere
and sit down
i look at them a certain way my dad used
to look at me a certain way get over
that boy and sit down if i didn't sit
down i got a good whooping
i just thank god did i change my life to
become a better father
it wasn't easy
you got to when you go to school you got
to be in the game
they gonna draft you and put you in the
game so nothing you can do
the big guys
used to try to bully us
but i learned how to fight i i was
fighting every day
every fighting every day every day for
my life
so it's gonna be war
it's gonna be war it's gonna be gun
battles it's gonna be fighting it's
gonna be killing shooting
even the bible even speak of that
there will be rumors of war
it's we're not going to go around it in
the hill of days look look what he was
doing so come on man
your kids have stayed out of the streets
well mind grown now my oldest one about
45 years old but then when they were
younger they were they was younger i
kept them in school they went to school
i made sure they went to school their
mama took she took him you know she
spent more time than me i was on the
street all the time but she didn't play
the mall oh [ __ ] knock them upside the
head
she'll knock him upside the head the
girls too she didn't play the mama don't
play
she don't play because she came from a
good family
you know i was the rough cat
meeting her she strayed me out by me
being a preacher kid bad bad little boy
but you know sometimes you meet a good
woman she can help you she can help the
man
a good woman can change a bad man
that you're at your
lowest point in your life you're
involved in things like prostitution
drugs stuff like that well i seen i i i
seen a lot in my days and i was no angel
and i i seen
so much
that
i had to get out in the street and do
what i had to do to feed me and my
brothers when i got grown because my
father
he got into a bad marriage and
he had it hard with the wife he married
so they was fighting all the time
arguing and
they couldn't get along so
we me and my brothers we think what my
daddy went through so hey man it was
hard and it was rough
and i like i said i'm glad to be
i'm in church i'm in the bible class
i'm in the ministry
you know i i i'm my
one of my pastors of pastor robert
junior skinner
it's my pastor he passed he had to cope
and i had to cope with too and i thank
god
i came out of the coma
for 17 days 43 and up 43 days in the
hospital
and i was messed up i thank god i always
took up myself i never drink i never
take drugs i work out in the gym i take
vitamins
herbs and stuff but
when i lost my brother he
he caught it
i stopped taking my herbs i stopped
i was broken down in the spirit i was
crying and
my immune system fell
and man i was out of it and i got sick
and the lord made a way for me to be
here today
they give you a new appreciation of your
life
yeah new person i'm looking good i'm
still looking good yeah you are
looking good riding good you know and
walking good and
i'm not in a wheelchair you know and uh
i thank god for my family they took care
of me and it's good to have
a family that can support you and help
you
every man needs somebody in this corner
so you means at home stop being
disobedient do right
do right
and the woman's that being disobedient
do right
and things will happen for you good but
it's good to have someone to take care
of you when you get sick are you still
married yes i'm still with my family i'm
not going nowhere can i go
i'm in my 60s now how long you've been
with your wife 45 years you've been
married 45 years 45 years i was a rough
cat
but what i did in the streets i didn't
take it home
certain thing you don't tell your family
everything that you do
you don't do that
you keep your family away from mess
man i had to i had to do things to get
pimples and milk send my kids to private
schools i don't really regret it today
if i had to start all over again i'll
live my life the same way
i did because i lived a good life
and
i was good at everything i did
if i want to knock on the door and do it
again i can do it again
sometimes
when you
walk across that bridge can you come
back yes i can because you got to do
right
you do right
right will follow you you do wrong wrong
will follow you you either going to go
the right way
or the left way right or left good or
bad
what uh what personality trait do you
possess that helps you help you get to
your life and come up well number one
i knew
my grandmama kept us in church all the
time and my daddy and my mama so i
remember
my mama used to say don't forget the
family prayer
whatever you do out there today
get on your knees and pray and talk to
the lord yourself don't tell your friend
about your problem tell the man upstairs
and he can help you that's what saved me
i don't live the life i used to i don't
have to and i'm not going back that way
but i'ma tell you
do the right things respect your mother
and father put a belt on pull your pants
up young man
do right respect your grandmother
if you have a mother and father respect
him but do right when you go to school
do not fight the teacher don't
disrespect the teacher respect is a big
part of it respect if you
got respect respect will take you a long
ways a good name better than money
and save you some money whatever you do
out there take care of your family
yeah i think when one gives respect you
you get respect as well you're gonna get
it i've been seeing guys man have
millions of dollars
laying on the sidewalk sleep every day
don't have no money
just like bobby womack wrote a song
harry hippy
if harry didn't want no help he wanted
to lay all in the
water lay all on the ground
if you don't want to help yourself i
can't help you but you gotta want help
and somebody will help you
but ain't nothing better than going to
church every sunday take your family to
church go hear the word ain't nothing
important and going to church and
staying in the word and that's what kept
me in what saved me staying in god's
house doing the right thing
is there still a little bit of hustler
in minister seymour oh yes hustling
going to stay in me i'm going to keep it
i'm not going to ever let it go i got
troll trucks man i got a company i got a
touring service i got a body and fitness
shop i customized cars i paint cars you
see them on pretty cars bishop dunn
magic one yeah i paint all these cars
them green and gold cars yeah paying all
them costs yeah he's probably been doing
that for decades hey man i just thank
god that i do have a trade
if you don't have a trade
go get your broom and sweep somebody
alley sweep their backyard sweep in the
back of their house take their garbage
out go wash their windows if somebody
gonna give you some money go walk down
the street ask the neighbors do they
need some help what you need clean up in
front of your house you need me to sweep
you guys can make some money it's a lot
of money out there go wash windows go do
something
go to the grocery store and help people
take their groceries to the cop but be
nice about it but people scared today
like we was coming up
they scared to even talk to you now
do you think it's just human greed
behind all these problems
that's not even the word it's worse than
that
you don't know who to trust people knock
on your door you can't even let them in
no more but there's some good people's
out there you gotta you got to let the
neighbors know that you're trying to do
something it's a lot of help out there
it's a lot of work but you got to go
look for it
somebody give you a chance is there a
lack of hope in the uh the poorer
communities it's some hope
it's some hope
but a lot of these like you mentioned
the young kids they grow up the parents
are in prison
they don't have an education they're not
going to have hope of anything great
happening well it's still they got a
chance they can get out there
and learn to clean up go knock on the
beauty shops barbershops can i take your
garbage out
can i clean up can i sweep the floor
somebody's gonna let you do something
it's a lot of money in the streets not
just only in drugs it's a lot of money
out there
the mexican and puerto ricans make more
man they make more money than a brother
ever thought of making a day
some cats get out there you go to home
depot they in the
lot
begging looking for work looking for
work that's what the brother got to do
now brothers come on it's a lot of work
for you out there to do
remember you're watching me
pay attention
somebody want to help you somebody going
to give you a chance
but you got to pull your pants up put a
bell on don't nobody want you to come
around the house man i couldn't come
around my my granddaddy house with my
pants is down he'll whoop my butt
you couldn't come around with your
panzers hanging down the cats won't put
a belt on man you guys got to put a belt
on
my grandmama didn't play that me
you can't pull your [ __ ] down in
front of them old folks they man they
will beat the hell out of you
so hey man
there's some hope out there but y'all
got to want to
man i've seen guys my age
i'm heading
towards 70.
i'm in my 60s i see guys how their
parents was all down to when i said man
good god of mine wait what the where you
going bro
push your pants was up
so then the gas station begging for
money
you got to help them i try to help you
got to give it you got to give it to
them you got to feed them you got to
give people something
and you got to pray for them you got to
love them you got to show that love man
tell them you love them hey man there
you go i love you man go look for a job
do you see yourself as a role model for
people like that i'm a role model for a
lot of people i'm a role fighter a role
model for snoop dogg snoop dogg was
leaving home one day
i said man go home to your wife
i told snoop dogg this
i told him go home
that's the best thing that could have
happened to you snoop dogg wait till you
get a lot of money and walk away from
your money
your wife needs you go home
i was at his party a few months ago he
told his wife this guy tell me go home
all the time and do right at all
i'm telling you the next brothers out
there tonight today do right go home to
your family it don't take all night to
do nothing
get in the house
get in the house
come out early
and go in early
that's all you got to do man
i've been to help a lot of people
a lot of people call me for help
and i tell them what to do
and i'm a living witness he's just a
good guy he's a good boy now got death
row
is this the best time of your life right
now yeah like i said snoop dogg got
death row jumping again
and uh i'm gonna be a part of his
organization i sing the gospel group to
myself jubilee travelers gospel group
mother and father put the group together
when was kids
so
hey
what can i do i'm working with the major
show lights getting a contract
universal records music i play guitar i
play with johnny taylor i play with
bobby womack
i play with uh tyrone davis man you know
uh
like i said johnny taylor
over right i play with a lot a lot of
cats you know and uh a lot of guys i
look up to like my cousin floyd skinner
chris righteous uh joy woodfork a lot of
good musicians i came up with some good
cats larry skinner you know i came up
nelson lockett you know these guys play
music with me down through the years
playing guitar that's what kept me out
of trouble playing the music
what's your biggest regret
i agree
i really don't i don't regret what
i regret i got sick
that's but i don't have no we don't have
no regrets man because i always tried to
walk
straight
so the guys all the great players
used to call me mr perfect because i
didn't get in trouble i didn't do wrong
i wasn't no angel but you don't let your
left hand know what your right hand do
whatever you do you ain't got to tell
the world about it
and that's why i last cause i kept my
mouth shut
yeah i think you're the most discreet of
anyone i've ever interviewed in the game
man i thank you so much man
because god is good
if you start praying things
happen for you more too
prayer changes things you know and uh
i got i i have a young nephew he's a
preacher
terry beard jr
my brother son and he's on the west side
over there park side in division
city of david that's a young preacher
good preacher i mean this boy bad
i mean he's bad he good
and uh
i just try to stay with the ministry and
listen to the word and
read the bible
and i'm just trying to walk a straight
line
and for the ones out there in radio line
go buy your bible ask somebody to get
your bible just start reading whatever
you need to know today is in the word
it's in the bible
and now it's time to run for the lord
that's what we can do now all the fast
stuff and played out i love the dress
and a lot of them probably don't
agree and understand what i'm going
through but i i serve a rich guy and i'm
gonna look good and
hey i like nice things if you like nice
things if you like a clean house you're
gonna have a clean house if you like
clean clothes you're gonna dress clean
you're gonna look good and i love to
look good i like the clean car i like to
be looking fresh
and looking like somebody and you need
to start doing the same thing going to
church stand in the word read your bible
and see how blessed you be because it's
in the word it didn't come from me it
comes from the word
all right minister seymour thank you so
much thank you so much for sharing your
story god bless good to see you again
okay god bless
you